[Music]
ford
the company that pioneered the modern
car the assembly line the hour work week
and the creator of america's
best-selling vehicle the f-150 despite
this impressive and long-lasting legacy
ford is currently in a rather dire
situation they've got over 200 billion
dollars worth of liabilities which puts
them in the top 10 list of most indebted
companies
while ford doesn't come in at the number
one spot something that we should note
is that all the other companies on this
list generally have a market cap that's
several times larger than ford so while
ford may not be the most indebted
company in the world they're usually the
most leveraged company in the world
thankfully they do have more assets than
liabilities given that their assets come
in at 257 billion dollars
but when we compare their cash reserves
to their liabilities it doesn't look
nearly as pretty ford currently only has
20 billion dollars worth of cash and
cash equivalents in other words their
total liabilities is 10 times their
current cash reserves considering this i
don't think you'd be surprised here that
macroaccess gives the company a 44
chance of bankruptcy now it should be
noted that ford is the only american
legacy automaker that has never filed
for bankruptcy in the past but this may
actually come back to haunt them because
they never got a reset switch like the
other automakers and this is one of the
main reasons that they still have insane
dead levels so is it just a matter of
time until ford goes bankrupt
taking a look back ford's liquidity
problems stayed way further than just
the pandemic or even the 2008 financial
recession in fact the route to ford's
financial problems can be traced back to
the late 1990s when a man named jack
nasser was appointed as the new ceo
jack was an entrepreneur at heart in
fact he had been running businesses
since he was a teenager he had a small
bicycle making operation and he ran
multiple disco clubs so it was only
natural that he brought his
entrepreneurial spirit into ford jack
didn't just come in as an executive
though he actually joined as a modest
financial analyst at age 20 in 1968 and
it was until 31 years later in 1999 that
jack would become ceo
in the meantime he had made a name for
himself as a shrewd businessman many of
his colleagues actually nicknamed him
jack the knife and blackjack jack the
knife was referenced to how many jobs he
had cut over the years and blackjack was
referenced to his intoleration for
unprofitable sectors while these are by
no means the kindest of trades many
successful ceos share these traits so
this in itself did not taint jack's
tenure what tainted his tenure and
screwed over ford financially was his
business decisions themselves first of
all jack tried to transform ford into
some sort of lifestyle company he wanted
people to have a high opinion of ford so
he started buying out luxury competitors
two of these acquisitions included land
rover for 3.3 billion dollars and volvo
for 6.47 billion dollars not only were
these expensive purchases but it also
led the ford having to split their
attention between the companies which
led to all the brands suffering aside
from trying to make forward into a
lifestyle company jack also placed a
massive emphasis on the internet being
an entrepreneur at heart it was obvious
to jack that the internet was the next
big thing and he strongly thought that
the internet should play a significant
role at ford so he spent loads of money
developing for its website affiliate
marketing it dealer portals and so on
these efforts were actually pretty
successful given that ford garnered
millions of visitors every single month
looking back these were pretty visionary
moves but jack missed the mark in two
areas first of all he was diverting so
much attention into the internet that it
was taking away from ford's core
business which was making it good cars
while having a good online presence is
definitely important as a car company
your number one focus should be making
the best cars you can and this was
unfortunately no longer the case with
ford as for jack's second shortfall his
timing was terrible
not only was jack too early for his time
but he was doing all of this right
before the dot-com bubble burst so when
internet companies crashed 90 to 95
percent in the early 2000s jack looked
like an absolute idiot and to a certain
degree he was he had completely
dismantled ford's focus on creating cars
while also burning billions of
acquisitions and the internet hearing
all this i don't think you'd be
surprised here that ford would replace
jack in late 2001 but the damage had
already been done
while jack was out of the company fort
spain had just begun first of all the
acquisitions that jack had completed
weren't performing that well they were
actually performing terribly but wait a
minute land rover and volvo were only a
couple billion each so how much could
this possibly hurt ford
well while the companies themselves
weren't all that expensive for ford
standards the same could not be said
about their balance sheets and cash flow
you see when you acquire a company you
don't just acquire the good parts like
the brand image and the customers you
also acquire the bad parts like their
dead and negative cash flow it's
estimated that holding jaguar and land
rover cost 4 35 to 50 billion dollars a
similar story can be seen with volvo as
well not only were these companies a
massive drag on forced income statements
while they owned them but ford would
also lose a lot of money trying to
offload these companies for example ford
would end up selling volvo for just 1.5
billion dollars as a reminder they paid
6.47 billion dollars to acquire the
company similarly they would end up
selling both jaguar and land rover for
2.3 billion dollars just nine years
before this ford paid 3.3 billion
dollars for land rover alone
clearly these were massive losses for
ford but this was just the beginning of
their problems you see oil prices would
reach nearly 200 per barrel in mid-2008
for perspective if you thought oil
prices were high a couple of months ago
these prices were 60 higher than that so
i don't think you'd be surprised here
that people shied away from buying large
pickup trucks and suvs given that they
would lose a fortune just paying for gas
and the given that large pickup trucks
and suvs were for specialty they were
basically screwed to make things even
worse the us was facing a serious
recession in 2008 which simply led to
four sales declining even more
all of this would climax with ford
losing a record of 14.6 billion dollars
in 2008 and at this point it was only a
matter of time until the government
stepped in and bailed out the company
ford would end up receiving a 5.9
billion loan from the department of
energy which allowed them to narrowly
avoid bankruptcy and start focusing on
developing energy efficient vehicles but
unfortunately for ford this was terrible
timing as well you see oil prices would
crash hard over the next couple of years
which meant that americans could once
again indulge in their love for trucks
and suvs given that ford was preoccupied
with cars like the ford focus this gave
gm the perfect opportunity to make
strides with their tahoe suburban and
escalade series and before you knew it
ford was falling behind in the same
industry that they had dominated for
decades so while ford was the only
legacy american automaker to avoid
bankruptcy it's not like things turned
out better for them anyway
over the past several years ford has
shifted their focus back onto what
they're good at trucks and suvs
they've even gone ahead and announced
that they're going to completely retire
the ford focus in 2025 it seems that
this approach has worked out pretty well
for forward given that they've been able
to make the f-150 the number one selling
vehicle once again
but it's not all good news ford has
never been able to work out the death
mess that they got into in the 2000s
sometimes their liabilities stand at 150
billion dollars and sometimes their
liabilities stand at 250 billion dollars
but for the most part ford hasn't been
able to reduce their average liabilities
to under 200 billion dollars to make
things worse the automotive industry has
been facing a pretty big crossroad over
the past couple of years with evs
fortunately ford has not been ignoring
evs like toyota forward has actually
been taking ev's extremely seriously and
they were the first legacy automaker to
convert a popular gas model to fully
electric so they're definitely on the
right track but this doesn't mean that
the path forward will be easy profitably
scaling ev production is extremely
challenging and ford is experiencing
this firsthand as we speak take the mock
e for example ford started maki
production in q3 of 2020 and they were
able to rent production for three
quarters but ever since then they've not
only been stagnating but declining when
you put the monkeys production ramp next
to the model 3's production ramp you can
really start to see how far behind ford
really is by the seventh quarter of
production tesla was pumping out over 70
000 model trees while ford was
struggling to pump out 15 000.
now it's not like this production ramp
was easy for tesla given that they
nearly went to bankrupt trying to reach
their production targets what this means
for ford though is that they have yet to
cross the hardest stage of scaling to
make things worse ford is having to do
all this during a historic supply
shortage according to ford's cfo
inflation along with the supply shortage
have completely wiped out the monkey's
profit margin so it's just gonna be even
harder for ford to be scaled than it was
for tesla not to mention it tesla never
had to deal with 200 billion worth of
liabilities either so at this point it
seems like all the cars are stacked
against ford whether it's their balance
sheet or their production capabilities
but one attribute that is working in
their favor is demand ford has over 200
000 lightning reservations and given the
popularity of the f-150 this number will
likely only go up with the time so ford
definitely has the demand to scale their
eva business to the next level and
remain a popular automaker the question
however is will the company survive the
transition
so far i know this video has been rather
negative on ford but they deserve a lot
of credit for many of their choices
at no point has ford tried to half-ass
the transition to evs the company is
literally all in on evs having committed
to invest 50 billion into evs by 2026.
also there doesn't seem to be any doubts
amongst leadership either it seems like
they all unanimously believe that
successfully transitioning to evs is the
only way forward this sort of confidence
and clarity is exactly what every
automaker needs
and honestly in my opinion if any legacy
automaker is going to make it to the
other side it's going to be forward but
with all of that being said it it's not
going to be an easy journey by any means
jack's well intentioned but poorly
executed initiatives from 20 years ago
are still weighing down the company to
this day and honestly there's no easy
way out for ford all they can do is
continue doing what they're already
doing try their best to transition to
evs while also protecting the financial
integrity of their company as much as
possible but only time will tell it if
their ambitious plans actually end up
working out do you think ford will make
it to the other side comment that down
below
also drop a like if you think more
legacy automakers should embrace evs and
of course consider checking out our
discord community such as future video
ideas and the consider subscribing to
more questions that possibly answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you